et pour parler du coronavirus nous
retrouvons barabara qu elle est
infirmière à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris et membre du collectif inter
urgence barbara coup et bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors en tant que professionnels de
santé quel est votre regard sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie
alors là c'est très cos après nous avons
quand même l'habitude dé des épidémies
hivernales avec
précautions d'usagé que chaque soignant
dans chaque service d'urgence doit
mettre en oeuvre pour se protéger et
protéger les autres patients qui sont
dans un service d'urgence après
effectivement sur ce virus spécifique en
france on a quand même aujourd'hui une
sorte de moment où de fluidité des
informations
les équipes sont vigilantes et sont
souvent en attente et réclame le
transfert des informations parce que
tout ce qui décide au niveau ministériel
n'est pas forcément encore à ce jour
arriver jusqu'aux au personnel de
terrain
alors on le sait les personnes les
personnels hospitaliers sont en grève
depuis des mois pour obtenir plus de
moyens
dans ce contexte les hôpitaux français
sont-ils prêts finalement à faire face à
une épidémie
l'exemple typique de ce qui s'est passé
à creil nos collègues à creil sont en
grève depuis elles ont passé leur un an
d'anniversaire avec des grandes
difficultés en terme de personnel c'est
vraiment la pratique de toute une équipe
qui a fait qu'elles ont décidé de tester
probablement ce patient puisque à priori
on n'avait pas de facteur et ça rentre
pas non plus dans les prérogatives du
ministère puisqu'il n'y avait pas de on
identifie pas encore comment il aurait
pu être contaminées au coronavirus sauf
que on voit que les équipes sont
toujours tous attentive à ce qui va se
passer et que elles sont aujourd'hui en
difficulté mais malgré tout à fond leur
travail le manque de personnel c'est une
réalité si l'épidémie devait arriver
aussi en france comme on a pu le
constater dans le nord de l'italie
de la même manière des lits il veut on
nous annonce qui sont libérés mais nous
au quotidien on sait qu'on n'a pas de
place alors un homme est décédé à la
pitié salpêtrière on le disait quelles
sont les consignes vous en parler un peu
tout à l'heure mais plus précisément les
consignes appliquées très concrètement
dans les hôpitaux
comment est ce que vous vous protégez
les consignes on a fait un bilan au
niveau national
aujourd'hui elles sont vraiment très
disparate entre les les services qui
sont les hôpitaux centres pour certaines
régions aujourd'hui sont au nombre de
138 ils ont été augmentés
on imagine bien que c'est pas l'ensemble
des hôpitaux qui sont mobilisés donc les
consignes sont différentes pour tout le
monde aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est ça
reste surtout le bon sens des soignants
on n'a pas plus d'informations
donc c'est on se protège avec les
masques ffp2 pour pouvoir
on ne peut pas savoir tant que le
diagnostic n'a pas été validé au niveau
des laboratoires si la personne est
infectée ou non donc à ce jour il va
falloir anticiper et se protéger au delà
de ce qui sera réel dans les faits alors
dans quel état d'esprit aujourd'hui
dans quel état d'esprit aujourd'hui vous
êtes ainsi que que vos confrères les
personnels hospitaliers avec qui vous
travaillez est ce qu il ya de
l'inquiétude
l'inquiétude non une lassitude puisque
finalement depuis ces mois de grève dans
les services d'urgence où on n'a cessé
de rabâcher que s'ils se passaient des
problèmes sanitaires de grande envergure
en france les urgences le personnel qui
travaille aux urgences sera présent
flora ce qu'il a à faire c'est son
quotidien
simplement à un moment la réalité elle
sera havas et aux yeux tout le monde
sait qu on risque d'être en manque de
personnel est en manque de place et
pourquoi
d'autant plus si le personnel tombe lui
aussi malade
donc c'est quand même un cercle vicieux
auquel on se demande quelle sera la
réponse du de notre nouveau ministre
merci beaucoup barbara coûts et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes infirmier à l'hôpital
lariboisière à paris et membre du
collectif interurbain ans le